this is a place filled with magic
everything has to have a reason the
movement of the grass the core of an
animal call of a bird
everything we're connected to all of it
and that is the most alive we can ever
be
this is a sanctuary for these incredible
animals just to be the way they've
always been
giraffe are disappearing everywhere they
exist but not here in the Okavango Delta
let's bear are perfectly adapted to the
open floodplains of the Delta so they
thrive
the boons are more like us and we would
like to admit they live connected to
each other in the world around him
while dogs are endangered threatened
with extinction with so few left they
are hardly ever seen
the hippo the Kabul that is the
custodian of these waterways it is the
engineer the hippo creates this
environment and without the hippo we
would not have the Okavango Delta but
while we moving through this environment
we need to be aware of this animal
if we lose these places then I think
we're all all lost and to our connection
to this planet that looks after us
that's why I say we want to look after
this one for children and the children
of our children we we want is ever to be
better it's a downward slide into
developments in people and tourism and
USC parts
it is a basic human rights to be able to
experience a wilderness like this after
18 days in the wild we are sad not happy
to be leaving returning to the developed
world that threatens these last wild
places so it's almost like a comedown
you know from an amazing place you just
start realizing that the whole world's
not like this every single one of us
will go to bed that night it's going oh
I wish I was back out there we all need
to do everything we can to preserve our
last remaining ordinances before they're
lost forever
rudeness places like this around the
world of formative to who we are as
human beings and without them we lose
something fundamental to who we are
you